Because if I was working for a more
sensitive organization, you know,
obviously it's a fucking
cage fighting promotion.
It's like how sensitive can you get? But
with some social issues, you know this,
like if I was working for the NBA,
I probably been fired a decade ago.
Yeah. These are the NMA is definitely
a, or the UFC has definitely a,
an animal in itself.
How did,
how did you get into that position?
Did you know the Dana White
and you started for you,
I, I always wanted to ask you
this and that at the comedy store,
how did you become kind of the voice of,
of the UFC?
Well, I started a, in 1997, I
was the post fight interviewer.
That was,
uh,
it was just a position that was available
in the UFC was very small back then.
Very few people knew what it was.
It was off a cable.
You couldn't get it on cable. You
could only get it on satellite. And uh,
they needed someone to
do post fight interviews.
So you were in that world to begin with.
I was in the martial arts world.
You know, I used to teach martial arts
for living before I became a comedian.
I used to fight a fight,
Atlanta taekwondo tournaments and had
some kickboxing fights and I'd always been
a martial artist since
I was a kid. And so, um,
I just was interested in watching the UFC
and then I started training in Jujitsu
and when I was training in Jujitsu,
I was just a white belt,
was just starting out.
That's when I got hired by the UFC
to be a post fight interviewer.
But I only did that for
two years and then I quit.
It was just too much and it was actually
like, it was, I was losing money.
I would make more money doing a weekend
at a comedy club than I would doing it
doing the UFC.
And it's just got to a point was just,
it was too much of a pain in the ass.
And so, uh, I still remained a fan,
but I backed away.
And then the UFC was purchased by
this company called Zuka in 2001.
And when that happened,
um,
they started putting on shows in Vegas
and I would go there with my friends.
They got me free tickets.
They reached out and they would try to
get celebrities to go sit there so that
it would, cause they were very small
at the time and they were trying,
they were hemorrhaging money and
they're trying to build it up.
And in talking to Dana
White one day, he, you know,
I was talking to him about fights
going on in Japan. I'm like,
have you ever seen Sato fight? Do you
know what, what do you do? You know,
soccer rod, you know, this guy at night.
And I was bringing all these names and he
was like, do you want to do commentary?
I'm like, I don't want to do
commentary, man. I'm, I'm,
I'm here to get drunk and watched
people kick the shit out of each other.
I'm not here to work.
And he talked me into it for one show,
UFC 37 and a half.
It was a show that was on,
I'm one of those, uh, Fox sports networks,
smaller networks. And, um,
I think it was the best damn sports
show period was a part of it.
I did that and the rest is history.
And then I did like 12 of them for free.
Like the UFC didn't have any money.
Well they were hemorrhaging
money and they had,
there were rich people that owned it,
but it was not a profitable venture.
And I said, look, just get me there. Get
me my friends tickets and I'll do it.
And so that's how I operated
like, oh, like over a year.
And then I just became the commentator.
It's this weird, that's crazy.
It's just Dana White. He's,
he's a crazy man and he's a,
he's got a weird way of
looking at things that,
that's very effective in his crazy mind.
He's like,
let's take this guy was never even
thought about being a commentator and make
them our commentator. I mean, I didn't
know what the fuck I was doing. I mean,
I really didn't, I didn't have any
training at all in sports commentary.
I just would see what was happening
and start talking about it, you know,
which is really like the wrong,
I was more even play by play and color.
It was like doing both of them at
the same time. It was really weird.
And as far as you doing that,
do you get any notes from anybody going,
hey Joe, a try this, try to add
or you just develop that whole,
that voice all on your own?
100% of my own. So the only
thing that I had was, uh,
there's like Mark Della Grotto. It was a
good friend of mine. He is, um, he's uh,
one of the top trainers in the world.
He's in the truck and uh,
I can communicate with him.
There's a button where I can communicate
with him and we talk about stuff.
Like I can say, uh, does he look like
he's limping to you? And he's like, yeah,
there's something wrong with his leg. I go
to the left leg, right? He's like, yeah.
And then I'll start talking about it.
Like I'll,
I'll be able to bounce it back and
forth with him. Or sometimes I just,
it's obvious and I'll say it myself, then
I'll, I'll ask him like it, am I wrong?
Is he dropped in his hand or his is,
this is a nice,
it's a nice thing to have
someone to bounce things off.
It used to be Eddie Bravo, Eddie Bravo
used to do it as well, where I would uh,
be able to talk to him about certain
positions because he would be in the truck
and I'd be able to ask him like, uh, which
his left leg is in jeopardy right now.
Right. Or He needs to step over with
his right leg. We'd be able to go over,
cause it's like there's some aspects
of martial arts that are extremely
technical,
especially Jujitsu.
When things go to the ground and you're
trying to commentary do commentary.
And I have to decipher which is his
left leg, which is his right leg.
Where is he tied up?
Where's he tangled?
And I'm doing it in real time while I'm
trying to be entertaining and talking.
It's very complicated, you know,
but nobody taught me how to do it.
I just figured out how to do it.
And you're not looking at it like, uh, uh,
Jim Lampley or anybody in the broadcasting
world when it comes to fights of it.
This is something that
you developed on your own.
Like sometimes you look at it as a
comedian, you look at other Comedians,
say the priors are Carlin's or whatnot.
Do you didn't have kind of like a,
a mentor?
No,
not necessarily because there wasn't one,
there wasn't a lot of guys that did it in,
in for martial arts
commentary. There was, um,
John Perretti who was excellent.
He was one of the very best who was
actually the UFC match maker and a
commentator when I first
started. He was very good. Uh,
there's a guy named Jeff Armstrong.
He was very good too.
He was there when I first started to,
he actually ran a promotion called
Hook and shoot. He's excellent.
He really knows what he's doing. And
then there's a few other guys, you know,
that also did it, but there's like
what I do as far as like stand,
uh, doing, um, uh, commentary for MMA.
There's might maybe 10
guys in the world to do it.
Yeah know they're really do it on
a high level. Maybe 10 guys. Whoa.
I mean between one FC, uh,
between, um, you know, uh,
brave and then the UFC Bella
tour PFL there's maybe,
maybe 10 guys on the
planet that are doing it.
She's not a lot of people and
there's a lot in the UFC now.
We're fighters are now transitioning
to become commentators and oftentimes
they're the best at it. Like Michael
Bisping just did this past weekend.
He was the UFC middleweight champion
and he's awesome at it. Already did one,
one show. They know more obviously
because they've been in there, you know,
they've, they have that added element
of actually having fought in the UFC,
which is gigantic. Yeah, I could
see, uh, I think Pauline Mala,
Mala noche. Yeah, he seems
to be very fantastic.
He's very good. He's very
good, very technical,
but also very aware and fighters can
see things that maybe the average person
can't see.
Like they see when someone's slowing down.
They see when someone's laying back, they
see when someone got hurt to the body.
They see like little things that may
be a person who's never fought before.
It doesn't say.